[Music]
if we go back to just the power of
information of what we believe
we fall in line behind certain
narratives either a patriotism or
identity of the organization we're a
part of and they're critical
but we also listen to information that
comes and influences us we are all
influenced by advertising we're
influenced by
slogans
we look at of course the master adolf
hitler
who created an entire idea that germany
had to come back into the world after
the first world war in a proud and
strong way and then he pushed a number
of ideas that were of course much more
extreme than that
but he was adolf hitler was still
popular in germany the day he was killed
in 1945.
now that's unthinkable because after 12
years of essentially taking his nation
of war and destroying it
german still believed in him because the
power of the message
was so
it was almost like a narcotic and we say
well that could never happen to us
well let's look at
tobacco in america
back in the 1940s and 50s it became
clear
that tobacco was a carcinogenic
and nicotine was of course highly
addictive
and as that information started to
become really logically irrefutable the
american tobacco institute which was
funded by big tobacco
implemented a very clever campaign and
they didn't take on the idea they didn't
say no tobacco doesn't cause cancer
what they said is tobacco may cause
cancer
they left a little bit of daylight and
they left each person who wanted to
smoke
they left them daylight to say well it
may cause cancer but it may not
and the american cancer institute played
this over and over enough doubt
so that people could continue to market
cigarettes people could continue to
smoke people could argue about that and
we realize how vulnerable we are
to
either blatant misinformation
you know what one side calls the big lie
but also to very subtle misinformation
which much of it is true and suddenly we
start to believe things
and act on those
if we look at the state of the american
political environment right now
we've got a polarization that is as
stark as i think we've seen since right
before the civil war
and there were strong economic causes
for it then and we don't have the same
root causes
now pulling us apart now they are more
tribal
they are more cultural they are more
informational
and the ability to have our mind shaped
if i was in tech right now if i was a
big tech leader
and we were talking about risks
i would get up in the morning and i'd
say i may have created the thing that is
going to destroy
my firm
meaning if i am in social media i may
have created
a suicide machine because that which
they have created is so damaging
that in fact
there will be a
a revulsion
against what is happening to our young
people and to a degree to ourselves
and so i think that if tech leaders
don't get in front of this
and start to understand it i could argue
the same may be true of artificial
intelligence as we start to employ it
more and we understand the impacts i
think that leaders have got to
understand
that the actual risk to them
maybe now in failing to get in front of
it
and act on that now and shape it so that
it is not as damaging as
it can otherwise be
you